pas l'été est là avec lui arrive le
temps libre pour les vacanciers est
l'occasion pour nous d'évoquer une
activité très française finalement et
qui revit des millions d'entre vous
l'été est d'ailleurs les airs aussi ce
sont les fameux jeu de cartes
alors avant de s'intéresser à l'histoire
des jeux de cartes à travers le musée
d'issy les moulineaux et de son maire
qui est avec nous et andré santini
on va vous proposer une tranche de vie à
nouveau ça se passe en alsace la partie
de cartes s'est pas seulement marseille
la partie de cartes vous allez voir en
alsace allait dominical et elle fait
partie du quotidien
virginie pichet sylvain gauthier part ou
non le jour ont fait joujou avec le
petit où on sort le chien et on s'excuse
de tout et de rien bref le jour où on
joue au tarot
ils sont loin pourtant les dimanches aux
anciens ou leur du seigneur rythme est
encore l'europe au sacré que les joueurs
de cartes endimanchés attendaient
impatiemment bien sûr moi j'avais mon
père qui était un ferme en joueurs de
tarot est systématiquement le dimanche à
la baisse c'est à ces deux heures de
temps aux essarts pro des arts à 14h la
province vers 18 heures c'était ce tous
les dimanches et toute l'année
depuis le progrès a fait son oeuvre mais
dans l'unique bistrot du village
aujourd'hui il reste une poignée de
fidèles démons du tapis vert les possède
depuis ce 10 mai 20 ans parfois plus
encore à la sab le mans gascon rené et
quelque chose on tape le carton pendant
des heures sanaa vingt places
il joue ici et par l'état n'ont pas
bougé car ici on ne plaisante pas avec
les cas dans les volutes blanche et
l'amertume de la bière le tarot prend
des airs de poker ici on devrait aller
quoi les sexes bonjour pas de quoi
s'enrichir juste quelques sous pour
pimenter le jeu le vrai plaisir
il est ailleurs ces moments agréables le
dégroupage et surtout je vais m'amuser
un workshop comme un amusement hamon a
joué dans nos villages puis de le
restera fermée alors que tu fous là bas
il faut trouver noté cela est aussi eu
tous des partenaires pour pouvoir jouer
s'ils n'appartenaient pas aux 10 km pour
une partie de tarot qu'importe
rené soit les deux autres ne
manqueraient ce moment à aucun prix
jusqu'à la fin ils seront pas enlevés
dernier jour de cartes dès dimanche
campagnard première remarque qui a pas
beaucoup de femmes au tour de table